[Musique]
patricia Darré et quelqu'un que l'on
peut dire de très très connecté non pas
qu'elle est à wifi ultra puissant ni que
ce soit une grande star des réseaux
sociaux mais elle est bien connectée
avec l'au-delà ouais l'au-delà l'endroit
au-delà c'est flippant quoi elle m'a
donné rendez-vous ici à la Mare au
Diable au bois de chanteloupe en plein
cœur du Berry le Berry berceau de la
sorcellerie
je suis vraiment content qu'on soit le
matin
et d'ailleurs vous êtes loin les gars là
les gars je sais pas si c'était une
bonne idée ça fait
[Musique]
ok ça commence fort Patricia comment ça
va
donner rendez-vous ici à la mare je te
laisse finir le mot
parce que on est au cœur du Berry du
Berry sorcier ici un endroit habitée par
le diable et le Berry sur le diable ne
serait pas le Berry on va commencer par
le début
une expérience de communication avec les
esprits aux alentours de la quarantaine
il m'est arrivé une expérience
effectivement assez inquiétante ça c'est
arrivé une nuit brutalement où j'ai
entendu une voix qui me dit lève-toi
écrit donc j'ai peur je me lève je
prends un papier à crayon et j'écris
quoi cette marque
tu es alors pas connecté mais genre
relié à une nouvelle dimension tu vas
voir et entendre des personnes et des
choses que tu n'entendais pas auparavant
tu devras juste en parler à ceux que
cela concerne alors mais pourquoi il y a
une croix il y a répondu tout seul
créer du pivert maudit donc la croix est
là depuis depuis le 19e siècle en fait
parce qu'on dit que un enfant aurait été
aspiré par le diable et serait mort noyé
voilà c'est parti de là la malédiction
de la mare lorsqu'elle est remplie il
faut surtout pas les baigner on en
ressort pas et les esprits et les
différences sur les fantômes et les
esprits moi j'ai toujours cru que c'est
la même chose mais non le fantôme lui il
est maudit l'esprit lui c'est l'esprit
de celui qui est parti et qui revient de
faire coucou les esprits sont positifs
mais il y a aussi des esprits méchants
ou alors les esprits méchants ils sont
des fantômes c'est ça la question
souvent c'est ce sont des fantômes les
esprits méchants
on va parler aussi un peu du berrichon
de patois de patois berrichon
actuellement là dans le bois au sud on a
encore des zones on parle très très
Berrichons
oui je vais te montrer la croix alors
cette croix c'est un calvaire typique
que l'on trouve un petit peu partout en
France mais surtout beaucoup en Berry
c'est la Croix où l'on vient ou faire
une prière à vendre partir à la mare au
diable ou alors quand on revient de la
Mareau diable on fait une prière pour
dire ouf je suis sauf je ne suis pas
tombé dans le trou merci Patricia pour
ce cours de sorcellerie et de berrichon
et puis comme disait George Sand le
Berry n'attire pas mais il retient le
Berry n'attire pas mais il retient bon
les gars
[Musique]
je suis retenu là Patricia au revoir
Camille